hi guys it's joanna here
if you want to burn belly fat and to
burn body fat quick
then this workout is for you the best
way to burn belly fat is to combine your
cardio workout with your core workout
this is a cardio and core intervals what
we want to be doing is four minutes of
cardio workout
with 2 minutes of core workouts the aim
is to complete 4 circuits under 30
minutes
i'll be showing you an easier version
for those of you who are beginners
and also a much more advanced version so
this
is suitable for everyone let's sweat it
out
so let's start with two minutes of
warm-ups
each workout it's going to last you 45
seconds
with 15 seconds of rest for beginners
what you can do is just to march on the
spot
okay this is to really warm your muscles
up
and to bring your heart rate up to get
you ready for the hard work
just relax and take it easy for those of
you who are more advanced
you can start to jog on the spot
okay breathe in and out really nice and
controlled
breathing remember without when it's
hardest and breath
in when it's slightly easier good job
all right just take it easy just easy
two minutes of warm up and now let's get
into jumping jacks
again for those of you who are beginners
and you find this difficult
what you can do is just to step side
to side all right
eventually what you want to be aiming
for
is to start jumping
good job keep going
you should feel your heart rates going
up
30 more seconds
good one now let's just slow it down and
let's just do 10
squats for our warm up so toes facing
front and just squat down
nice remember to push up with your heels
and push your bum out tighten your core
and the first workout we'll be doing
it's called
shutter stats
good so what you want to be doing is to
bend one leg
and to bring one knee in
okay so try to keep your body as low as
you can
and to bring the other knee up
good what you should be feeling is your
glutes working
your left leg working at the same time
you're tightening your core
to keep your balance keep going good
you can speed it up now let's change
side
same thing i'm just going to take a step
forward to avoid
myself from kicking right
alright so bend your knees keep your
body low
feel your butt working
that's it good
rest for 15 seconds the second workout
what we want to be doing
is jump squats with four punches
okay straight punches left and right
beginners what you can do is to start
squatting down four punches really punch
all the way up
down one two three four down
one two three four and eventually
get into a jump good
jump it out quick punches
and go really push all the way out
feel your legs working and your arms
working at the same time
okay i don't want to see gentle punches
i want it to be tough and hard
good job work your shoulders work your
biceps
keep going last one
good wrestle fit in 15 seconds third
workout
plank up and down okay what we want to
be doing
is to go get into a plank position go
down
back up jump in jump out okay
down up jump in
jump out beginners go on to your knees
up step in step out
down up step in
step out let's go up
jump in out good
keep going
you should already feel that it's
getting harder and harder
this is a really good total body workout
and it's incorporating
your core at the same time keep pushing
good just feel more
out
in out rest
fourth workout wide squat burpees
okay so what we want to be doing is to
get
jump out jump in a super position
and jump up okay let's go out
into a sumo position and up beginners
what you can do is to jump in jump out
and just stand up
right let's go out in jump
we all hate burpees but that's the
reason why
everyone is doing it because it's a
really good total body
fat burning workout you should also feel
your inner thighs
as you're getting into the super squat
position keep going
this is your last cardio and we're
getting into
our abs good
down onto the floor core workout
okay knee tucks support your upper body
and just bring your knees in and out
okay
you should feel your total core working
ready let's go in and out
okay try to breathe and focus on your
core
alright you should really feel
that your legs are dying right now
just support yourself all right
only 30 seconds for each core
workout keep going
last one good
still on the car get down what we want
to be doing
is to keep our legs straight on top of
each other
bring it up crunch up alternate
back down crunch up alternate
don't touch the floor back up
alternate down back up
good so you're really feeling your lower
abs
and your upper abs working good
keep going last few
up last one rest
good job one more corner workout
plank with knees down so get into your
plank position
what we want to be doing is to bring
your knees down
and touch the floor and bring it back up
okay without moving your upper body
what you're actually working on it's on
your lower
abs good just keep going
alright good job gentle knee touches
keep going this is your last call
workout
and after this we want to repeat
the entire circuit again
good job now
10 seconds rest the first workout
shorter steps okay bend one legs
ready go step back and crunch it in
good job keep going
make sure you're really bending your
right legs okay keep your balance
and feel your glutes and your bum
working
good job change side down
up okay look straight ahead
to keep your balance keep going
okay your heart rate should be
rocket high this is how
oops we burn fat
last one good
next workout jump squats with
four quick punches okay
take a breather ready
let's go arms up jump
four quick punches good jump
really punch it out and feel your
shoulders
and your arms working it's really good
to tone your arms up
at the same time so really keep your
core tight
and your body straight keep going
okay try to land gently
on your toes good job keep going
come on punch it up one two three four
good punch it out one two three four
last few more one two three four
last one good rest
next playing up and down with
a hop okay so choose
the easier or the harder version
ready let's go down
up up in and out
good job keep going
it's a really good total body fat
burning
workout you've got to work hard
for your health and also for the body
you want
last few more
keep pushing ten more seconds
out five more
good rest
next workout burpees in a sumo squat
position
okay oh that's your last one and
then we're doing our car ready
let's jump squat jump up
good out sumo squad
feel your inner thighs and up good
keep going
same thing divineness you can just stand
up
instead of jumping up good
for your inner voice working
not far now
few more
one more
rest down onto the floor
into knee tucks
okay come on let's push it
rest and go
in and out good job
really extend all the way and bring it
in
only 30 seconds for each call workout
nice and controlled
keep pushing it
last one and down on the floor
straight onto crunches with scissors
okay wakes up
go crunch up change down
make sure you're doing on the other side
of the legs now
last one good let's get into
playing with knee touches i promise you
after this
you will get a one minute break so let's
go
plank gentle knee touches down and up
to really work on your lower core
good gentle
touch gently
okay halfway there
keep pushing you're getting you deserve
one minute rest after this
last one good
rest for one minute do whatever you need
to do
wipe your sweat ignore that
wipe your sweat drink water and just
take a breather
okay
all right 10 more seconds to rest and
get ready for your
second circuit the first workout
is jump rope okay
there you go so for beginners
just imagine you have a rope in your
hands and just jump
jump double feet if you need to jump
side to side
or you can even just mix it up be
creative
okay and make sure you're not going too
high because what we want
is to be working on our calves good
double jump jump
side to side good
okay let's bring our heart rate
up again
how does that feel come on just another
10 more minutes good
and rest for 15 seconds just watch it
out
the next workout it's going to be a hop
side to side so one two hop bring your
knees up
one two hop okay so make sure you're
balancing on one side
one two hop one two hop
good pop
pop land on one side
it's going to look weird but it's really
good
for your legs and your palm
keep going make sure you're landing
your weight on one side of your feet
good go wider
as you get into the movement
okay hop pop
good
up up up one more
and just match it out third workout
what i want you to do is to start
from your right side squat and jump into
your left side
and punch up four punches ready
down jump four punches up
beginners you can just step step
and punch up right ready go
bust into it down burst into the squat
movement
right really push with your heels
up down bus
oh my god first into it good
keep going jumping movements
really bring your heart rate up that's
why
it's a really good core and fat
burning workout last one
good job match it out okay
fourth cardio workout it's like mountain
climber
except what you want to be doing is to
bring one leg
right beside your palm okay this is
called the groinus
there you go just take a step
and bring it to the side of your palms
okay as you get more advanced
add a hop into it okay
there you go i'm just gonna take it easy
for right now keep going
step in step out
good keep pushing
at the hop if you can do
let's go 10 more seconds
you should feel your invites
working as well good job
next back to our two minutes of core
lie down on the floor
okay one legs up
one legs down and just crunch
and reach the opposite side okay
god my room is so tiny and just crunch
and reach that's it
and let's do this for 30 seconds
and we will be
swapping over so really twist
a few obliques working
good one more
good rest i'm going to move down
slightly
and now change side i'm getting confused
go down up
like you really crunch up good
make sure you're holding your head but
you're not
pulling it good job keep going
up touch your toes
keep the leg straight and crunch all the
way up
one more rest
the third call workout it's going to be
superman with the back raise
arms on your forehead squeeze your upper
back
and just squeeze your back good
relax your lower body and just squeeze
okay
you should be feeling your lower back
and your upper back working
as you're squeezing it in good jump
so hands on your forehead squeeze it in
bring it down
up squeeze back down
up squeeze one more
good rest for 10 seconds
and we want to be doing the whole
workout
again ready
ready let's just
jump ropes good okay
side to side
land on the left side to the right
side and make sure you're moving your
wrist at the same time
double jump good
all right single next workout
is to hop side to side
good
keep going
double jump
always there rest
the next workout jump jump pop
okay one two land on one feet
ready same thing beginners you can just
step it up
bring it up step and bring it up
step bring it up okay
let's go one two hop one two
hop good
bring your hands up to give you the
extra balance
good knees as high as possible
good keep going
i'm drenched in sweat
up good keep going
come on you're almost there
this is your last circuit
pain is good good rest
take a breather next workout squat
and jump to the other side with four
punches
okay
let's go let's keep pushing go squat
jump one two three four good
power up with the heels good
push it
keep going
and remember punch really hard all the
way up
do not cheat with your arms good
keep going down
jump always there
come on last 10 seconds down
jump let's do three more jumps
last one
rest good job next workout
groiners like mountain flavors but groin
is
okay down on the floor
i'm going to take a rest for a while
bring it up and step it in good
all right if you feel energized
you can always jump into hops
okay i'm feeling quite
tired today all right
keep going push it
halfway there this is your last
cardio workout
make into the hops good
keep pushing
five more seconds last one
rest last three cold workouts
and i promise you you are done
done on the floor
start with your left side arms out
crunch and touch good
touch remember to support your neck
but don't pull it
only 30 seconds
really twist
good job
last one good
change side
it's got such limited space all right
let's go up good
okay if you have
a small space like mine just bend your
arms
slightly good crunch it up
up good job
keep going
keep pushing last one rest
now your last core exercise
superman with back workout down
arms on your forehead behind you up
squeeze
good job up squeeze
doing good really feel low back and your
upper back working
your lower back it's part of your core
good job look down up
and squeeze just a few more
let's do two more one more
squeeze and now
just rest it out let's do
two minutes of cooldown right now okay
just stretch it out
take a breather take your tongue if you
need to
and now let's just start by
crossing your leg over okay and just
twist your body
and look one side this is to stretch
your glutes out and also the side of
your abs
just twist
control your breathing bring it down to
a controlled place
okay and now what you can do
keep your legs in the same position and
just reach forward and you should feel
even more stretch on your bum
all right if you feel that you need to
stretch longer hold it for longer
and now let's let's change side across
twist and stretch it out okay
look as far back as you can for a deeper
stretch
and now cross your legs left leg on top
of right and just reach forward
all right and now
let's bring it up and stretch
knees 90 degrees open up your arms and
just
arch it back and just push your bum
forward you should feel the stretch on
your legs
and your upper body as well
and one last one change side
and stretch it out
and very very very
well done to your 30 minutes cardio and
core
interval workout i am
absolutely dripping in sweat and i hope
you are as well
if you were to do this entire workout
without stopping according to my video
you will be looking at burning between
270
to 350 calories it is a lot of calories
for a short
workout so do it two to three times per
week to win total body fat
as well as to burn your belly fat this
workout is also part of my 90 days
weight loss challenge in the second
month so you can check my workout plan
out
and start that as well remember it takes
lots of hard work and dedication to
achieve
the body you want so workout
sweat and all the best for new fitness
food and motivational videos please like
share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website
do follow me on facebook instagram and
twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys